Paul 66 percent of Voters say Joe Biden
is too old to serve four more years a
majority of Voters 66 percent believe
Joe Biden is too old to effectively
serve another four years as president
according to quinnipeg poll Republicans
and independent largely hold this view
while Democrats more divided with 57
saying Biden is not too old
in contrast only 37 percent of
respondents think former president
Donald Trump who is 76 is too old uh for
second interesting 37 percent compared
to 66 percent uh even though they're
only five years apart age-wise
Republicans Independence lean towards a
belief that Trump is not too old while
Democrats are split on the issue
Washington Post back up backed up focus
group also highlighted negative
assessment of Biden's physical abilities
and mental health would swing state
voters questioning his agents
speculating about dementia can you play
that clip by Jake Tapper please if you
have it
here's Jake Tapper uh uh on the show
yesterday
uh talking about uh uh you just had it
Rob the age
and I just have it a minute ago
I did let me I'll grab it right now you
know what happened when they told when
they asked Joe Biden what he thought
about the poll you know what he said
what are pulse he had no idea what the
hell they were talking about he just
walked away he started shaking hands
with the air probably he said I haven't
been too generous club for many years
that's probably yeah
every president's job
he's like God make it bigger there we go
that's hilarious as far as I remember
can we play as we're helping the
Ukrainian can we play this audio I can't
hear it yeah we played this yet CNN it's
fine so reaction you know what they need
all the views they can get facts you
can't do audio
audio's up on my end
okay all right so Tom when you think
about a poll like this how how how
important how critical this is Rob can
you just check to see maybe another clip
can play that how critical is this when
you see 66 number like this is there any
Credence to this poll or is it just
another thing that they're showing here
there's a lot of credence what happens
is remember how bad the pollsters did in
the last two elections how wrong they
were you could take the results of the
election and go down a list of polls and
there were very few of them that were
within their previously stated margin of
error right now so let's separate the
polls and talk about the American psyche
the American psyche right now has seen
Trump on CNN they saw
um DeSantis announce live on Twitter so
the election is at the front of their
mind and so the closer we get to
election the more we get more people
show up in What's called the likely
voters because remember they do the
polls you'll see him that says
registered voters and this was a poll of
likely voters would you say you're a
likely voter yeah I'm pretty pissed off
what I just saw I'm definitely gonna
vote so the likely voters right now have
been activated for the moment and
they've all woked up and said if the
election was hit today you're a likely
voter what would you and everybody's
saying this gosh you know with China
with the economy with everything I I
don't know this is real this is very
real but does it mean that the Dems are
going to pull back on
on the you know the the cardboard cutout
that currently is serving as our
president I don't know if they're going
to do that because they're they're
running the country
behind him right it's a proxy we have we
talk about proxy wars we have to all
understand right now right now we have a
proxy president that's what's going on
right now we need to think about this
and it's not and it's it's it's it's not
Kamal of the cop who you know you know
what I feel about her as the AG of
California and the devastation she had
right now people are close Pat and their
their second guessing it and they're
saying I do think age is an issue this
this is very real because the voter for
the moment has been activated this is
all going to subside we're going to go
in the holiday season and then they're
going to pop back up in January but do
you think Tom that the age uh situation
is going to be big enough to have those
voters that we talked about Adam because
you're the Vegas numbers on all the ones
that I looked at has Biden in number one
Biden is the favorite to become the
president do you think the age is enough
because I don't think it's about the age
I believe it's not even about his
policies the voters that are voting for
him are going to vote for not Trump
that's what it's going to be at the end
of the day so it's a not Trump vote you
know how I feel and I think Pat me he'll
speak for himself but I think he's
coming on this page too I believe the
proxy president stays in place until
they decide that the Health crisis is
there I think Michelle steps in and she
is your Democratic Michelle Michelle
might I think she's oh you're saying
that Michelle Obama's gonna step in all
of a sudden yeah I've been dismissing
that here for years at this point I
don't think she might be the one
um
to your point on Vegas I think that will
crystallize and be cemented once there's
a candidate from the Republican primary
and then that person whoever it is Trump
to santis will be the favorite uh listen
for anyone that doesn't think that the
age is not a problem you're living in
life
one more thing please so
you know what is it 70 66 think that Joe
Biden uh is too old 37 and by the way
did you see what number of percentage
people think that Ron DeSantis is too
old to run uh zero nobody people that
that's not a concern but so I think I've
said this before the juxtaposition if
this were the case of Trump versus Biden
on stage we've seen that movie before
we've seen this play out but Trump I'm
sorry DeSantis versus Biden the the
competency and the age disparity would
be so glaring that DeSantis will just
walk his way into the White House just
because you have a 44 year old man
versus a 84 year old man it's so
polarizing and such a just glaring
situation whereas Trump is only four
years age difference I don't think it's
going to be that big of a factor when it
comes down to the election time yeah I
mean the the reality here is that people
value they don't value competency what
they value is how the candidate makes
them feel versus the real Trump elicits
a lot of uh you know strong feelings
from people the race is always an
[__] build the wall a little bit good
he's a bigger but at the end of the day
was the United States a better country
with him in office yes it was I mean
when I was an agent and he was uh
president were arrested and taken down
some of the worst people we're putting
more pedophiles in jail we're getting
into more criminal aliens the country
was Stronger when Trump was in office
versus now the guy can barely you know
have a speech ready and or speak
coherently even when there's a
teleprompter in front of him so the
thing is is that people value how they
feel about it Canada over the candidates
competency which goes to show you that
we live in a very [__] stupid world
where people lack critical thinking
skills we talk about this all the time
uh policy versus personality and what do
you think most people vote based on
policy no you're wrong Personality yeah
most people are gonna vote based on you
don't like Joe Biden's policies I don't
know what I'm saying I'm joking most
people are one or two issue voters it's
the it's the economy stupid or it's
abortion or it's immigration or its guns
or it's health care whatever it is they
got their one or two issues that they
care about but they're not going policy
by policy policy by policy they're just
like all right I hate Trump's tweets
he's out Joe Biden's a piece of [__]
he's out and that's just how people vote
and and the thing also is that like you
know people went off after Trump for the
you know grab her by the [__] comment
blah blah blah we're talking about a
clip that was over a decade ago it was
locker room talk when he was you know a
star Etc and if you don't think that men
talk like this behind the scenes then
you're just not living in reality of
anything I want a president I'm able to
relate to I'm able to sit there and have
a conversation with I love watching
Trump's interviews like he did with full
sent Etc you can see that the guy is a
personable guy people can hate him
whatever it may be but regardless you
got to take out his personality okay is
he a good president did he do good
things he did it's it's pretty much
irrefutable but people are more
concerned with how Trump makes them feel
yeah versus what he's doing on the real
hard to separate that's exactly right it
takes a deep crisis of a Nation to get
people think about the real yeah but
during a deep crisis they will I saw
polls
um that were like 90 days after 9 11 are
you glad George Bush is president or
would you have preferred Al Gore it was
shocking it was all the way over why
because probably 90 something percent
exactly at that point because you know
what they were thinking they were going
about thinking wait do I want Gore the
hand ringer pacing around the Oval
Office or I want the knee Breakers here
and Dick Cheney was seen as a knee
breaker and so people were all lined up
with you know what but it takes a crisis
like that to get people to go to the
real otherwise it's perception political
but it also he was even Jake Tapper from
CNN watch this when he had to give this
poll horrible news horrible for Joe
bideners
go back please I can't hear anything you
guys are talking over it's 15 seconds go
ahead horrible news horrible for Joe
Biden our new CNN Paul while the
president leads his Democratic
competitors by a huge margin two-thirds
of all of the American people surveyed
66 of the public say that Biden Victory
would either be a setback or a disaster
for the United States
that's not a script by the way he's
getting more credible incredible by the
day by the hour Jake Tapper wait is that
news or is he making an apology Jake
Tapper was like making apology yeah dude
he said he said horrible twice horrible
news horrible for Joe Biden I'm shocked
that even they didn't cut him off can
you just give CNN credit for a second
for years they were feeding us nonsense
and this is actual it's not CNN that's
what I'm saying I'm giving him Credit
Credit not CNN give Jake credit for the
work that he's done here here and by the
way he cannot stand Donald Trump so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
foreign